The Roman Empire.
Is there another empire?
Quite like it in western history,
the nations of the Western world look back on Rome as a kind of forefather.
Many of the empires which followed wrong from Charlemagne to Mussolini,
even the empire is or Britain,
France and Spain,
which are much larger than Rome ever was in many ways,
modeled themselves in Rome's image.
The Word Kai's are Caesar even remains the word for emperor in many languages
today with a similar connotation and English.
And that is not the only word that the Romans gave us.
Many European languages in general are in fact echoes of the Latin language,
which the Roman spoke,
including partially English and language is only one aspect of our daily lives
that originated in ancient Rome.
What was wrong?
Everyone has heard of at least some parts of Roman history,
but how often is the whole story told from its origins as the humble,
maybe despicable city state to its rise as a magnificent and unparalleled empire
to its catastrophic collapse.
And this video,
we are going to tell that story.
This is the full history of the Roman Empire.
MMM.
Before we begin,
I would like to thank Jeff Carpenter,
Darra Shariat and Stefan [inaudible] for being our most recent supporters on
patriotic.
They join the supporters who help make videos like this possible.
And I would like to thank all of you for joining us in our first documentary or
2019 as we now add Rome to the list of peoples and nations whose history we have
fully covered.
The story of the foundation of Rome is one of both a myth and fact,
which historians still endeavor to separate many of the names and events crucial
to Rome's early foundation,
maybe last forever,
but the legend perhaps contains important elements of truth.
Well,
Legend tells of two twin brothers,
Romulus and Remus,
descendants of the Trojan,
a niece and sons of the god Mars and the Princess Reyes Sylvia,
who were ordered to be drowned by a jealous uncle.
Wait,
seize power from their grandfather.
It King of a city called all the longer the twins were secretly spared.
However,
in set the drift and the Tiber river in a basket where they were later
discovered by a she wolf who nurse to twins back to health.
They were then discovered by shepherd who raised them into adulthood as adults,
Romulus and Remus discover the true origins and would eventually kill their
uncle and restore their grandfather to his throne,
but we'll then go on to found their own city where this city was to be founded,
however,
and who its king would be.
Quickly became a matter of debate.
Romulus won that debate by killing remiss and as Legend states on April 21st
seven 53 BC,
he built his city on the hill and as its first king named it after himself,
Roma Romulus eager to attract a new population and invited all of them he could
to settle in Rome,
but it quickly became a city filled with the dregs of society thieves,
outcast criminals,
and runaway slaves.
Romulus then formed a government which included 100 men from the city's leading
families,
the poetry's or fathers,
and thus established the Roman Senate.
Though the population was growing,
it was overwhelmingly male.
Obviously a problem and the long term,
but the inhabitants of Romer so undesirable that women from neighboring lands
were entirely on interested in marrying them.
Accordingly,
Romulus would organize a massive kidnapping of women from the neighboring towns
and cities.
This led to wars that could have potentially destroyed Rome had the women
themselves.
It's not intervene to avoid becoming both widows and fatherless.
It's a fascinating story,
but it's unclear what truth there is to it.
Much of it is very obviously fable,
including even Romulus,
but the Romans somewhat knew that the events and characters of the story,
however,
as I said,
maybe representations of the real work of the early Roman peoples and their
interactions with the metallic peoples around them.
It's also a surprising story and that'd be Romans who would later thinks so
highly of themselves would claim to be descended from reprobates who his actions
where a criminal and shameful.
What we do know factually is that the area around Rome was inhabited for
thousands of years.
The earliest discovered habitations maybe from as far back as 1000 BC in the
eighth century BC,
Rome was a smaller city state.
Frankly more like an unimpressive town.
The Romans were surrounded by other Latin peoples and more broadly other
Retallick peoples such as the Etruscans,
Sabine's,
umbrians and Sam nights with Greek colonies having been established in the
south,
the Greeks a more powerful and advanced civilization at the time were very
influential to Italy's early development.
Things like their religion,
their system of writing,
their trade,
technology and culture would be adopted by the people as of ancient Italy and
slowly become Roman,
but true regional power at that time.
However,
it was not the Romans,
it was the Etruscans people mysterious to us.
Still though not a single nation,
they were a common people who at times worked collectively.
It is likely that the Romans did not simply mimic the Greeks,
but they mimic the Etruscans who had partially mimic degrees.
The very location of Rome for the more and the center of Italy along the Tiber
river was likely chosen apart from its natural defensiveness because it would
benefit from the trade between the Greeks and the Etruscans.
From the eighth fifth,
sixth centuries.
BC,
Rome remained a small city,
state and habited by simple people ruled over by what Roman historians say,
where a series of seven kings keep in mind this period too,
however,
is very unclear and probably partially fictitious as is much of the history
until three 90 BC.
But we'll get to that in a moment.
Rome was indeed likely Kanombe in the eighth to sixth centuries BC.
The last king was the tyrannical King Taran who has said to a rural from fire 35
to five oh nine BC and one incident his son is said to have raped and important
noble woman named Leucadia.
In response,
the incident sparked rebellion under Luke ewas units.
Brutus,
Brutus and his comrades succeeded and vanishing the royal family,
but instead of appointing a new king vow to never have another and formed the
Roman republic and five Oh nine BC who was the real Rome,
now say not [inaudible] loose Romanos the Roman Senate and people abbreviated s
p Q.
R.
Much of the Republican design such as the Senate was already in place from the
beginning,
even under the kings.
For.
This was still a major step at the head of the government were to elected
councils who would serve a term of just one year.
The Senate consisted of,
as was previously mentioned,
men of the aristocracy at least 30 years old.
Younger politicians were seen as too brazen and in fact the word senator comes
from the Latin Senex,
meaning old.
Uh,
senate is therefore according to the Romans Anyway,
and assembly of elders.
Not everyone born in Rome was a citizen and of those citizens,
only a minority.
We're patricians the highest class,
the majority of Roman citizens.
We're born into the class known as play peons who held little power in the city
at this time.
The majority of the population,
however,
consisted of non land owning men and women,
slaves and a stork,
non citizens upon its foundation.
The Roman republic would resume it's conflict with its neighbors and very slow
absorption of the lands in central Italy.
This is not the glorious Rome with which we are familiar.
Rome was still just a city on the edge of the known world,
ruling over about 10 square miles of land.
Rome would remain a city state for the next century and a half.
In this time,
there would be important social developments as the play begins,
fought for him greater influence and the government of Rome and struggles which
would last for over 200 years known as the conflict of the orders.
During this conflict,
a number of play being consular tribunes were established and roan came up with
the idea of appointing a dictator in times of troubles.
The word dictator did not have the negative meaning it does today.
Dictators were to take on the full authority of Romans government during times
of crisis but resign after around six months.
By the fourth century BC,
the Celtic peoples of northern Italy and France known as he calls began moving
south.
It is recorded that in 400 BC,
a group of Golish Celts called these unknown A's under King Brenna's cross the
Alps and again attacking the northern Italians.
Eventually they reached Rome.
The Romans mounted at offense,
but at the battle of alia the Romans were crushed and the goals then moved into
Rome itself and sack the city.
This is the Afa mentioned incident,
which destroyed many of the prior historical records.
The Gauls would not stay,
however sagging the city was sufficient for them.
Legends say they were later fought off by a general named Marcus.
Foodie was Camillus who boldly told them that the Romans defended their city
with iron,
not gold.
However,
many historians today do believe that the goals were bribed with goal to leave.
Either way,
this event reshaped the Roman mindset and the recovery period is sometimes
referred to as the second founding of Rome.
The Romans developed a fear of the barbarians of unknown lands and rediscover
the importance of the defense of the Fatherland Rome.
Soon return to becoming the foremost city and he,
Talia and its neighbors started to notice from 348 PC to two 90 BC,
a series of conflicts were fought in Italy,
most notably the three satellite wars against the Romans neighbors,
the Sameon after whom the Sam night wars are named were among Rome's earliest
great rivals.
The two would fight for dominance over all of central Italy.
The Sam neons would be able to count on many other allies,
including the [inaudible],
a trust skins,
other Italian peoples,
and even the goals.
Yet by two 95 BC,
the conflict started to wind down with the battle of sending them in which the
Romans defeated a combined to Gatwick and Sam the enforce the odds were against
the Romans from the beginning,
but their successes here,
it could be owed to their unwavering persistence and spirit following Rome's
victory.
They would control the majority of the peninsula and we begin to see that these
are indeed a people who have the potential to build a mighty empire.
Rome was not really operating like a real empire at this point for much of the
history of the republic and Intuit's later years as an empire conquered
territories,
we're not always fully annexed,
at least not right away.
Often they were turned into clients,
states retaining some autonomy while owing some tribute or service to Rome.
What each state owed varied from situation to situation.
But in these early days,
Rome usually simply sought military support in times of war.
Rome was now a true power,
but great power often attracts powerful rivals to the south,
stood Magnar,
good Ikea,
the Greek colonies in Italy and on the surrounding islands of Sicily,
Sardinia and Corsica,
where the Carthaginians nation people who built a wealthy and powerful
Mediterranean empire from their capitol of the same name and Modern Day Tunisia,
Rome and the Greeks would be the first to combat each other.
The Greek colonies.
At this time,
we're disunited and Greece itself was not a unified nation at this time either.
The Romans would exploit this division,
a tactic they would use frequently.
As time went on leading to conflict with multiple Greek Italian cities,
Rome.
Now a military machine could have easily rolled over the Greek city states.
However,
the colony is called upon allies from Greece itself.
Coming to the rescue was an ambitious king purists of a Pirus,
a second cousin of Alexander the Great.
He arrived in two 82 BC.
Beginning one is remembered as the period wars.
This was a monumentous classical showdown.
The Macedonian Phalynx would soon face.
The Roman Legion.
Purists would engage the Romans in two major battles Hara Clia and asked for
them.
His soldiers and command proved superior as he won both times with no small
thanks to his war elephants,
which sent the Roman men and horses,
many of whom had never seen anything like an elephant fleeing and panic.
But these victories had come at great costs,
purists last crucial chunks of his army.
In both battles,
he planned to rely on recruiting new men from the countryside and defeated army.
But he found few volunteers.
The loyalty of the Romans had surprised him.
This was a problem.
He knew that whatever losses the Romans took,
they would be able to replenish their troops faster and easier.
And thus,
this is the origin of the phrase,
a pyrrhic victory,
referring to a victory which has cost so much that it is effectively at a feat.
Such was the case with purists who had beaten the Romans but lost his army in
the process.
And in two 75 BC at the battle of Bennett vent them,
the Romans would attack the Greeks.
And finally the feet,
the withering forces purists returned to Greece and the Romans Annex,
the Greek colonies.
Rome had beaten the Greeks,
but they would not stop here then with soon,
seek out new conquest,
transforming from a humble republic into an imperial republic and empire,
which the Western world had never before seen.
However,
for the time being,
standing in their way was the mighty empire of Carthage.
Soon Roman Carthage would clash in a series of wars,
which would last for over a century and haunt Rome for the rest of its
existence.
The Romans referred to the Carthaginians as Phoenicians or poo,
Niki.
They were at this time like their phone,
each and ancestors,
the dominant Mediterranean traits people,
but Rome feeling quite confident after a string of victories had it's eyes on
some prominent Carthaginian Holdings.
Both empires had their eyes on Sicily and disputes here would lead to the first
Punic war in two 64 BC.
This would last for 23 years.
It was fought on both land and sea and it wouldn't become one of the largest
conflicts ever fought up to that point on the face of the earth.
Rome sign number of successes here against Carthage on land,
but learned early on that it was behind Carthage at sea.
And thus it is in this conflict.
That emphasis is first placed on Rome's navy.
An important step on the road to empire.
The Roman simply lacked the Carthaginian naval technology,
the Queen Queer Kareem's massive ships with five rows of Oris destroyed Roman
vessels repeatedly.
Historians believe that eventually the Romans happened upon a destroyed Quinn
Queer Kareem and learn to reverse engineer it to create a navy which could
finally challenge Carthage in two 47 BC,
the famous Carthaginian General Hem Ecar Barca enter Sicily and use guerrilla
warfare and clever tactics to hold the Romans off for years.
But finally at the naval battle of a God,
he's in two 41 BC,
the Romans scored victory and the first Punic war came to a close.
Carthage suffered a heavy to feet and faced with financial difficulties soon
fell into civil war.
Wrong took advantage of the situation.
And NXE islands of Sardinia and Corsica Carthage crippled by instability could
not prevent this and allowed it,
but they would not forget it.
Eventually the rebellion was ended and Carthage under hemoccult Barca move to
claim new territories and Iberia before he left.
However,
he made his nine year old son swear that he would harbor eternal hatred for Rome
and it's people that young boy would grow up to be one of history's greatest
generals and thus one of Rome's greatest adversaries.
His name was Hannibal of Carthage in Rome,
remained a piece for some time each focused on other affairs.
Rome focused on the northern Golic Lens and Carthage was recuperating and
rebuilding US army.
By two 20 BC,
Hannibal have become a commander himself,
still retaining his sworn hatred for the Roman people and planning revenge.
He had developed plans to a knock that revenge slowly but effectively and got to
work in two 19 BC.
His first move was to be seized.
The city state of Sagoon tomb,
a strategically important Greek city state in Iberia,
allied to Rome to Rome.
The Carthaginian assault was a casus belli not long after war broke out,
which would be much more draining and devastating to Rome than the first Punic
war.
This would be the second Punic war.
This is one of the most important wars of Roman history and frankly one of the
largest and most important wars in ancient history.
Hannibal had already shown signs of becoming a talented and effective commander
and was greatly dedicated to realizing his ambitions.
For now though,
the question remained how exactly was he to reach Rome?
The Romans had control over the islands of the Mediterranean and had you served.
Kartha does role as the major naval power,
the Romans,
confident in how they expect that animal to act,
what sends some forces to Sicily and would send other forces to Iberia under a
general named [inaudible] who was Cornelia was Skipio the elder daringly
Hannibal would not resort to using a navy to reach Rome.
Instead,
he would move around through modern day France to attack Italy from the north.
By crossing the alps,
it was a treacherous journey.
Many men and animals perished on the march.
Some lost their footing and fell.
Others died from the harsh cold.
This was especially the case for the war elephants.
Others died in combat with some of the local Celts.
In total sources claim Hannibal would lose over half of his army,
but he successfully arrived in northern at the end of October and two 18 BC
catching the Romans completely off guard.
Hannibal replenishes forces with local Gullix at port and a number of battles
soon and sued each of them going very poorly.
For the Romans,
at the battle of Trivia and at the battle of Lake Tresor mean the Romans will
lose 30,000 men.
Both times the Roman people have become grill concerned.
They were clearly dealing with the commander of considerable skill.
Thus they appointed a dictator Quintess Fabius maximus.
What ecosys known as Fabius Fabius wanted to take on a new strategy against
animal,
sometimes referred to as quick topwater that a layer because of it,
he would not pursue direct glorious battle.
He knew all too well how capable Hannibal was of handling that.
He also knew Hannibal supplies in the region were limited and his gallic allies
we're not interested in.
I drawn out war.
Therefore,
he began a war of attrition,
avoiding direct battles in scorching his own country's food supplies in an
effort to where his enemy out.
A tactic now known as the Fabian Strategy.
Not all of his commanders would see eye to eye with them on the strategy,
though the Romans were I proud and brave people.
They viewed this tactic as cowardly and dishonorable.
Eventually Fabius resigned from the office of dictator and new consoles who
would change.
The tactics were elected.
These more aggressive console's put together the largest Roman army ever
assembled.
Up to that point,
at over 85,000 men,
this massive force met the Carthaginian army of around 50,000 men near the city
of Kanye.
On the 2nd of August two 16 BC can,
I should have been the deciding Roman victory.
It did not turn out that way.
The Romans recklessly attack the Carthaginians.
Hannibal quite simply annihilated this force after cleverly managing to surround
them at least 50,000 men,
but quite possibly even more,
were destroyed by the Carthaginians who lost only around 6,000 men.
Panic spread across the country.
Not even the mightiest Roman army ever assembled could be Hannibal.
To make matters worse,
King Philip of Mastodon began to support Carthage.
At this point,
only a few battles in Roman history.
Could compare to what happened at Kenai.
The Romans nevertheless scrambled to rebuild their army and quite wisely decided
to reemploy the Fabian strategy.
All the while the war on other fronts when favorably for Rome and Iberia
commanded fallen to the son of skippy or the elder Skipio,
the younger later known as Skipio Africanus skippy or the younger had volunteer
to become commander after the death of his father and uncle,
he would soon prove to be the right man for the job.
He would take the importance city of New Carthage,
the regional capital,
and what drive the Carthaginian south back into Africa itself.
Hannibal was a military genius,
has government,
however,
did not share this genius.
The Carthaginian government failed to reinforce Hannibal's army can die and then
failed to respond when Rome turn the conflict around in the years afterward,
sending troops to reinforce other areas instead.
By Two oh seven BC,
Rome had retaken it's loss territories and invaded Carthaginian land at the
battle of La Skipio.
Afrikanas would deal a crushing blow to them effectively reverse of Kanai into o
two BC at the battle of Zama near Carthage itself.
Hannibal was defeated by Skipio us,
one of the few men who could challenge him,
and Carthage finally surrendered in two o one BC.
This defeat was a crushing blow to Carthage.
It was not destroyed,
but lost the vast share of its territory and became a Roman client.
State.
Rome,
despite all at lost,
came out of this war with clear profound gains.
It was now in control of the east of Iberia and was becoming a true empire,
one which now that its greatest rival had been knocked out was a master of the
Mediterranean.
Hannibal would eventually be forced out of his own country and sent into exile
where he would fight the Romans on the side of other armies until he committed
suicide and one 80 to OBC to avoid capture.
One might expect at this point for Rome to rest on the laurels of its victory.
The second Punic war was greatly strenuous and Rome now have the opportunity to
exploit its successes,
but to the east Macedonia.
Under Philip the fifth west supported Hannibal remained a threat to their new
found dominance.
Rome would attempt to stamp out this threat by exploiting the division among the
Greeks,
allying itself with Pergamon and roads.
Greek city states who are under attack by Philip.
This would lead to war with Mastodon in 200 BC only a year following the second
Punic war,
Rome entered into the region declaring that it was doing so on behalf of the
freedom of the Greeks.
The ulterior motive,
however,
was curving Macedonian expansion and power.
The war would last for three years and ended in a Roman victory following the
battle of scene assembly,
but the larger Greco Roman struggle was only beginning.
This struggle would be another major event in world history.
As a whole.
The light of Greece was fading and that of Rome was burning brighter.
With Phillips Defeat,
Rome declared Greece was free,
but in practice still retained forces in the region.
Seeing what was happening.
Some of the Greeks does look to yet another foreign power to liberate them from
foreign rule.
This time,
the solution empire of Anatolia and empire,
which was a Greek successor state to Alexander the Empire Division emerged among
the Greek cities.
Some favored Rome,
others the solutions tension with soon break into conflict,
Sparta had been the most resilient to Roman influence and met the Romans at the
battle of Gilliam and one 95 BC,
Rome and its allies.
It would be victorious here and one 92 BC.
The I told Ian League invited the solutions under Antioch is the third into the
region as liberator's Rome was joined by the Archean League and other allies and
thus began the syllabus said war.
Within the first phases of the war,
the Romans scored an impressive victory at the infamous ancient battle ground of
Thermopylae at the battle of Magnesia and one 90 BC.
The solution space,
another crush and defeat and the war easily ended and Roman victory.
With the conclusion of this war,
Rome was beginning to catch a glimpse of its future.
It had beaten as regional competitors and was indirectly in control of their
lands.
Mastodon would make another attempt to resist the Roman one 79 BC under Philip
successor per se,
us and what is called the third Macedonian war.
Perseus was joined by many of the Greek cities,
which had opposed Rome in the past and for a time it seemed as though massive
don was going to truly defeat Rome,
but at the battle of [inaudible] and one 60 ABC per se,
as his ambitions fell apart here,
his phalynx encountered it's historical arch enemy on even terrain,
and the more flexible Roman legions tore them apart,
killing perhaps around 25,000 of them while losing less than 1000 with
opposition falling apart,
Currys was now completely subject to Rome,
though piece followed this conflict.
Many Romans were still anxious of the threat of potential rivals across the
horizon.
One such anxious Roman was Cato,
the elder who finished every speech he made in the Senate,
regardless of what it was about with a short phrase,
k,
Ted ohm can say,
oh,
Carnegie numb essay,
the London.
And furthermore,
I believe Carthage must be destroyed.
Carthage was certainly not what it used to be.
It's military prowess had diminished with the loss of Hannibal and the Romans
would soon take advantage of their situation.
Both the fourth Macedonian war and the third Punic war began in one 50 and one
49 BC respectively.
Both engagements,
we're smaller than their predecessors.
The fourth Macedonian war was a Greek uprising that ended in failure and one 48
BC and the third Punic war was focused mostly around the three year long siege
of the city of Carthage,
Carthage,
his last stand and one 46 BC,
the adopted grandson of Skipio Afrikanas Skipio I Emilio [inaudible] took the
city of Carthage piece by piece.
Once the walls were breached,
the Carthaginians fought for every block wants taken.
The population of around 400,000 was either massacred or enslaved and the entire
city was burned to the ground.
Despite common legend,
the Romans likely did not actually salt the earth around Carthage.
Part of the motivation for invasion was after all,
Carthage is agricultural abundance.
Rome was now the undisputed master of the Mediterranean and it is following the
year one 46 BC that the Roman Empire with which we are familiar becomes
recognizable following that a feat of its enemies.
The tremendous energy of this new would turn inward as the focus came to be on
the competition between rival politicians.
Two of the most famous figures of this era are the [inaudible] brothers.
Key Batty was Tiberius and Gaius Krokus.
Both of them were populist in nature and work to better the Roman number
classes.
The most famous of their attempted reforms was the redistribution of land from
the aristocracy to Rome is urban poor and veterans,
both of them would overstep the boundaries of their offices and even Ron from
multiple terms in a row.
Remember,
of course at a console had just a one year term and could not run again for
another 10 years.
Both of them would die in the process that groggy brothers,
while only somewhat successful in themselves highlight at the beginning of
changes to the Roman republic.
That would alter it forever though the waters of the Mediterranean where now
more tranquil.
The Romans never ignored that threats which could come from the mysterious
north.
And that is around this time that the Romans encounter another hostile European
people who would in time prove themselves to be as fearsome and more challenging
to the Romans.
And even the Celts that Gary Amani,
but Germans around the year one 13 BC,
three Germanic tribes in particular with Celtic mixture,
the Kimberley to Tony's,
and then bronies began moving south in search of more hospitable lands.
As they approached Roman territory,
they assume,
proved willing to actually turn around.
The tribes had likely heard of the great power of the Romans,
and when they were asked to negotiate by Niosh,
[inaudible] was carbo.
They did so and agreed to leave foolishly carbo.
Either they believe in these invaders to be a threat or eager to obtain a
glorious victory in battle.
Planned an ambush around the paths through which the tribe said they would be
leaving.
The tribe's learned about this,
however,
and we're prepared for the ambush.
When it came,
the resulting battle of Noria was a disaster for the Romans,
the majority of the room,
and Forrest was destroyed and carbo barely escaped.
In one o five BC that Armani returned and the Roman sent an even larger force to
the northwest to deal with them under two generals,
[inaudible] and maximus.
These two men were from different social classes and often did not see eye to
eye.
When it became evident that maximus of a lower social class was planning to
negotiate a truce with the German tribes.
Kpo of the upperclass ordered his half of the army to attack the Germans.
The resulting battle of a Roseo was a disaster for the Romans,
like at Kenai bravado was to blame for the egregious error that caused the Roman
armies to be divided and annihilated.
The Romans lost around 120,000 men here,
maybe even 60,000 more than that can I?
With the Germanic tribes losing only around 15,000 in terms of total men lost
the worst defeat in Roman history.
Yet Rome would recover and put a man named Gaius Marius on the scene.
Gaius.
Marius had recently proven himself as a commander in North Africa and had
already served as console once the Roman Senate.
However,
desperate for strong leadership allowed Maurice to serve again as console and
one o four BC.
He would be reelected four more times consecutively and wood in total serve as
console seven times in his life.
Why?
Well,
simply put,
he knew what he was doing.
Surprisingly,
the Armani did not attack Rome after Roseo.
Instead they moved off to Hispana.
Mario has capitalized on this luck and used it as an opportunity to reorganize
the Roman army down to its very basic structure.
He made it a standing army as opposed to one which was called up during times of
war,
but perhaps more importantly,
we organize the laws surrounding entrance into it prior to this and individual
had to hold a certain amount of land to join the army.
The intention here was to ensure that the interest of the army were in line with
the welfare of the state.
Marius sooner moved all property requirements,
allowing the port enter.
He would also have these soldiers begin carrying their own supplies.
Prior to this,
slaves and animals did this job.
Though this would lead to his soldiers being called muhly Mariani,
Maurice,
his mules,
it made them much more mobile and put them in better shape.
He promised land grants and pensions to these soldiers who completed their term
of service and one of the three BC bigger money return.
Their intention was clear to sack Italy,
but at the Battle of Oak,
why 60 I Mario's proves his reforms were successful and Delta crushing blow to
them killing 90,000 and enslaving another 20,002 years later,
they met at the battle of where Kelly,
where Marius was again,
greatly successful,
taking very few losses but killing perhaps 60,000 Kimberly and effectively
ending the Kimberley and war.
Marius was a hero and bore this title proudly and his political life,
but those successful in his military pursuits,
he was less successful on the field of politics.
He sought to retain his power at times resorting to bribery and assassination to
do so.
Ironically,
his behavior in the political arena would set the stage for the downfall of the
very republic which he had served.
Perhaps one of the most worrying signs of things to come was the mindset of
Mario's.
His soldiers.
He may have served the republic,
but his soldiers served him because generals,
we're now responsible for the welfare and the eventual pensions of their men.
Marius had created an army more loyal to their generals than the government in
Rome in the nineties BC or rebellion and the land surrounding Italy erupted as
the peoples of Rome's client states fought for Roman citizenship after pointless
fighting,
the Senate caved and granted citizenship to the Italian peoples willing to lay
down their arms.
Many agreed,
but the Sam Nian rebels led the group still resisting intending to found their
own state.
Pursuing them was the Roman General Lucas Cornelius Sula Sula as he was known,
was primarily responsible for bringing the social war as it's called to a close
and was made console as a result in 88 BC that same year,
the first myth road datic war broke out in the east,
sparked when the king of Pontus,
a Persian state and modern Anatolia methodologies invaded a Roman territory and
began to kill all Romans in one of history's first genocides Sula as council
prepared to lead an army to deal with this threat,
but he was pushed aside by the now elderly Marius,
who intended to lead one final campaign.
Sula would not stand for this and would end up doing the unthinkable.
He gathered his forces and marched into the city of Rome itself to depose
Morris.
It was illegal,
shocking and sacrilegious even,
but at work and Mario's fled to Africa.
Sulla then took a man of the army again and moved east to deal with the pontic
king.
Why the way,
however,
Maurice and his ally,
Kenna marched on Rome themselves and over through a seller supporters.
However,
Maurice died of old age.
Within a few weeks of his seventh console ship and Kenna will be stoned to death
later on.
Fortunately for Sillas as well,
the warrant in a Toyota was going favorably and he was able to claim a glorious
victory and then return to Rome to take power by defeating his rivals once again
in a brief civil war.
Once his rivals were defeated in Scilla second march on Rome,
Cilla took on a title which none in Roman history had ever before.
Received dictator for life.
Cilla now effectively held absolute power for as long as he wanted though he
ruled cruelly and the end,
much of his work as dictator was spent trying to prevent someone from doing the
same thing he had again and he would resign his dictatorship after just one year
service council for another and then retire,
but his intentions would fail.
Ironically,
he and Maurice had already set the precedent for a new form of government to
arise and the man who would bring about the end of the republic had already been
born.
This man is perhaps the most well known Roman in history.
Gaius Yulia was Kaiser,
Julius Caesar.
The language segment for this video usually included in these documentaries in
which we'll talk about Latin will be made separately after this documentary,
so stay tuned for that.
The first century BC was an eventful time in Roman history.
Two more Mithra detic wars were fought in the modern day,
Middle East.
They were quite draining and to make matters worse,
in 73 BC as slave uprising,
led by a former Thracian gladiator named Spartacus,
that place which spiraled out of control becoming a genuine rebellion and was
only put down by Marcus [inaudible] Crassus in 71 BC,
a separate revolt occurred in Iberia around the same time,
which was put down by a general named Niaz Pompeius,
better known as Pompei,
both classes and pump pay.
We're making names for themselves.
The two would both service console and 70 to 69 BC and metro detic wars in the
east finally came to a close in 63 BC and Rome subsequently expanded further and
to Anatolia and the Middle East having to feed Pontiss and Armenia from pay for
the Moore was active in the region and took the city of Jerusalem that year.
This was also the same year that the great Roman orator,
Kiko,
or an English Cicero was made console.
They'll way controversial figure of his day.
He would spend his career defending Rome and even protected it from a takeover
by a rival named Catalina.
This was as we've seen,
not the first to Teton Rome,
northern last.
The political situation we have been discussing was creating a hostile
environment in Rome,
bribery and corruption,
assassinations of violence,
street gang violence and general disorder.
We're all common.
It is in this turbulent environment that the aforementioned leaders crassness
and Pompei join forces with another political star.
Julius Caesar.
Caesar was from a family of minor nobility.
He was well educated and had a talent for writing and oratory and was involved
in politics and the military early on by 60 BC.
He was around the age of 40 and seeking higher political office.
It is in this year that he joins forces with pump pay and crosses in a political
alliance known as the first triumvirate as Rome's most powerful figures.
The alliance quickly saw some success and Caesar was made console alongside
Marcus called Peroneus BBU loose.
Those Caesar soon held full authority.
Caesar was just getting started in 58 BC.
The infamous gallic wars began.
It is here where Cedar truly made a name for himself as he waged war and
expanded into the territory of the galls of modern France,
while also encountering a number of Germanic peoples along the way.
These wars would last for eight years and he would even venture into Britain and
your Manea.
Though his gains there would be less permanent throughout these wars.
Cesar would find a number of competent and trustworthy allies,
including Marcus Antonius,
better known in English as Marc Antony Caesars access here is largely ode to his
skill as a commander.
He was an excellent commander and motivator and often entered battle,
not from the back as an observer,
but from the front alongside his men.
I've mentioned before that this was a period where the army's sort of had more
loyalty to their own generals than the nation because of the roles they're
general would play,
but this was a more personal loyalty.
Consider what it would mean to you as someone in during the life of a soldier
campaigning in a colder,
mysterious land against armies of ferocious larger men who oftentimes spot naked
seemingly without a fear of death and brutal up close and personal and the hand
comment and standing there right by your side in the heat of battle is your
commanding officer facing the struggle with you,
not willing to send you into something that he would not.
Also in deer that spoke volumes to his men.
In the latter half of these wars,
Caesar's suffered a string of bad luck.
His success in foreign lens brought concern back home.
A man who could wield so much power and authority could pose a serious threat to
the welfare of the republic.
In 53 BC,
the triumvirate itself began to break down.
Crassus died while campaigning in Syria at the battle of car high against the
Parthians Caesar,
his daughter and pump his wife Julia had died shortly before this and palm pays
seem now to be less interested in alliance and more interested in furthering his
own career,
making him Caesar's rival political tension erupted into violence and even the
Roman Senate building burned in a fire pump.
Pay will become sole console in 52 BC.
Meanwhile,
Caesar still caught up campaigning in Romans.
Frontier suddenly found himself up against a new opponent,
the Great Celtic leader first and get her originally a leader of only a single
gallic tribe first and get our expert form alliances with numerous others and
led a United rebellion against the Roman occupation first and get her ex was
initially quite successful and pursued a war of attrition against the Romans,
which wore them down.
He would even defeat Caesar at the battle of gear via.
However,
in 52 BC,
Cesar would defeat the goal is once and for all at the battle of Elisa.
Following this,
the gallic wars started to come to a slow halt and Modern Day France was
incorporated into the Roman Empire.
Caesar then returned to Rome to deal with matters there.
The Senate demanded Caesar dispend his army before returning to the city,
but Caesar had other intentions upon crossing the Rubicon River in northern
Italy.
He had broken the law by marching into the heartland with his forces before the
fateful crossing.
He is said to have said,
I'll AI [inaudible] the die is cast.
Cesar knew where this would lead yet another civil war on the opposing end,
his old friend pump pay who fled the grease upon his arrival,
he sees her med palm paid there at forest soulless where despite being
outnumbered two to one Caesar defeated a pump,
a pump,
hey then flood to Egypt,
but he was murdered by Caesars Egyptian supporters before he could catch up to
him.
It is here where Caesar met the Egyptian queen of the Ptolemaic Dynasty.
That is to say a descendant of the Greek rulers of Ancient Egypt,
Cleopatra,
Caesar and Cleopatra would develop a close relationship here of a political and
intimate nature and she would even bear him.
A son [inaudible] in 46 BC with his rivals aside,
Cesar would become more than just another general who had marched on Rome.
He would be named dictator for life and was contented to remain as such,
but much of the Roman elite,
including Caesars former friends such as Marcus,
you and Eos,
Brutus,
we're firmly against him fearing the return of a king.
On March 15th 44 BC,
I date known as the ides of March 40 or so.
Senators led by Brutus acted on their fears of the new dictator and surrounded
and stab Caesar to death,
though Shakespeare claims.
Otherwise,
historical sources say Cesar fell silently in shock covering his face with his
toga.
Instability followed Caesar's death.
The republic would not return to its prior state.
Rather,
different factions arose to claim succession.
Marc Antony Caesars former comrade had effectively taken control of Rome
following the incident.
However,
it soon emerge that Caesar had named an heir to his fortunes.
Gaius [inaudible],
an English Octavius,
his grandnephew,
whom he had adopted as his son and his will.
Octavia has posed a significant challenge to Marc Antony briefly.
They fought it out,
however,
with a Senate trying to undo them both.
In 44 BC,
they joined forces with Marcus.
I Emilia was labored to us to form the second triumvirate.
The second triumvirate would take control of Rome and the three would share
power as dictators.
Octavius a frail 19 year old boy was initially the weakest of the three,
but he would soon prove to be much more ambitious and cunning than its
counterparts had imagined in 42 BC,
Octavius and Anthony,
to feed it a sentence forces at the battle of Philippi in Greece.
Here,
Brutus and Cassius Caesar as a main assassins,
died in battle.
They would also pursue and kill other hostile senators such as Cicero with the
Republican leaders.
Out of the way,
the three divided the empire between themselves.
Tony took the east Octavius,
the West,
and [inaudible] Africa.
Though,
in 36 PC Octavius would take control of lipidosis territory himself.
Meanwhile,
in the east,
Antony prepared to take on Parthenia to do so.
He had secure the support of local client leaders.
One such client leader was Cleopatra,
much like with Caesar,
the two fell in love and would later have children.
By 32 BC.
The larger inevitable conflict started to brew as Octavius and Anthony became
hostile toward each other and each sought total absolute control of the empire.
The war that erupted is often known as the final war of the republic.
It would last for two years and would come to its conclusion at the naval battle
of Actium where Octavius defeated Antony and Cleopatra is forces.
The two lovers later committed suicide and Octavius took on full control of the
Roman Empire.
Now in his thirties with this great victory,
Octavius would simply known as our Wooster's Augustus Caesar Rome's first
emperor Romans,
now in 27 BC to be exact at true empire with a true emperor.
Yet it retained its Republican psychology.
It was a nation of the Roman Senate and people working in unison.
That's the image Augustus wanted to display anyway.
Augustus never dare to call himself a rex king.
Rather,
he simply perpetually held multiple powerful offices and stack the Senate in his
favor,
which gave him absolute power.
He preferred the title preen caves,
Kiwi totties,
the first citizen,
a formerly senatorial title,
along with being the first emperor.
He would also be the longest ruling over a United Rome anyway and would have one
of the most eventful and important rains in Roman history.
His reign march,
the beginning of what is known as POCs or Romana the Roman peace.
This was a period of relative peace and stability in Roman history,
which would last for over 200 years.
It was not a time of complete peace instability.
There were regular conflicts and wars,
but they were primarily fought outside of Rome and without much damage done to
the empire within.
It is under Augustus that in the modern nation of Israel,
Jesus of Nazareth was born though his birth is what traditionally divides the
calendar between BC before Christ and 80 [inaudible].
He was actually likely born around four BC.
Jesus Christ is easily one of the most important figures in human history.
His followers today would say the most important.
I plan to cover his story and other religions in future videos.
For now though,
it will suffice to say that his teachings would go on to become the religion of
Christianity,
which would shake the Roman Empire to its core.
However,
Caesar Augustus would never hear his name for the moment the only son of God and
the Roman empire was Augustus.
His adoptive father,
Julius had essentially been deified by now.
Jesus Christ was crucified around the year 38 d and died shortly after.
Though,
of course,
central to the Christian religion is the belief that he rose from the dead three
days later,
despite being regarded as the bringer of POCs.
Armana Augustus would fight a number of wars throughout his life.
It was his belief that Rome would be in a turtle nation,
which ruled the whole world and expanded into the Balkans,
the Near East Africa and the rest of Iberia.
His most famous horse,
however,
her fought in Germany.
They're Manea was the frontier of the known world to the Romans.
Had was in this age,
mysterious on developed and alien,
likely much more so than even Gaul and 12 VC campaigns into mock nugget of
money.
I began.
Rome began a process of aligning themselves with the dramatic chiefs and
bringing them under Roman rule and law.
To accomplish this,
some dramatic chief's sons were taken as hostages in a sense to be raised in
Rome as Romans and return to gear Manea as leaders sympathetic to Rome.
One such German was a boy who the Romans would call our minis,
who grew up in the Roman army,
climbing the ranks quickly.
What the reputation of being a fine soldier when our mini [inaudible] was asked
to accompany the Roman General Puglia's Quintilian is waters into gear Manea on
a campaign in seven eight d he was suddenly forced to choose between his Roman
life and his German life.
In September of nine eight d his choice was made.
Arminius secretly became a military leader of his people and trick the Romans
into passing through a swampy,
heavily forested route to suppress a fake revolt.
Here,
Arminius and his men were able to ambush them and to feed them decisively and
the battle of the two dimeric forest known to the Romans as cloud days Wadiana,
the Varian disaster,
what is and 20,000 of his men were killed.
The survivors were tortured and ritualistic be sacrificed.
When Augustus heard of this defeat,
he evidently began to bang his head on doors and screamed,
queen titty [inaudible].
They won't sred quintile these Walrus.
Give me back my legions.
Why all the losses here were major.
They were only a fraction of what was lost at Kenai or Rossio and comparison.
Nevertheless,
some historians placed at two to Barrick forest as a Rome's greatest defeat
because of the effect that had on the empire.
The frontier was set at the Rhine River.
The Romans would cross it,
but never really ruled the land beyond.
Augustus died in August of 14 a d age 75 his reign was profound,
but who would succeed it?
The Roman emperors would not always behave like the later European monarch who
often left their rule to family.
Generally the eldest son leaving rural to a family member was coming,
but there was never a single clear way in which the Roman emperors were chosen.
Largely because the Romans never stopped seeing themselves as a republic effect,
which will become a huge problem in the future.
Leading to a number of civil wars in general,
political strife,
the rural did often go to a family member.
The approval of the government and military was also crucial.
In this instance,
the succession did peacefully fall to Augustus's adopted son Tubarius.
He in the next three emperors were all family and thus this is regarded as the
Julio Claudine Dynasty by Historian T.
Barriers was a skillful commander in the past,
but quite noticeably did not enjoy the position of emperor and achieved much
less than his predecessors.
He would die hated by the people as a paranoid,
frugal and ineffective ruler in 37 eight d probably kill the by his successor.
His successor would be even worse.
In fact,
insane Emperor Caligula is known to many as one of history's most absurd rulers.
It is uncertain which stories about him are true.
The sources aren't always reliable,
but according to stories brought his horse to a dinner and threatened to make
him a console and pregnant at his sister claimed to be a god killed innocent
people for Amusement and declared war on the God Neptune.
Having a sodas collect seashells on the coast as a war bounty.
Caligula is often portrayed as an incoherent madman,
but modern historians suggest there was a method to his madness.
The horse console incident was likely a way to humiliate the Senate,
which challenged him a way of showing how unimportant they were to him.
The seashell incident was likely to humiliate his soldiers for resisting his
ambitions to cross into Britain and his sexual relations with his sister may
have been influenced by the thinking of the Egyptian Pharaohs were incest was
common.
Caligula was killed by his own body guard.
The praetorian guard,
when he announced he would be moving into Alexandria after just four years of
his reign,
the Praetorian guard would later find Caligula's uncle Claudius hiding behind a
curtain and made him amber.
As we've started to see,
the Roman emperors are a list of very colorful individuals.
To put it simply,
Caligula was not the only emperor to behave or radically as we will see,
and I think that it is important to point out that for every great Roman emperor
who held the empire together,
there was another terrible one who nearly tore it apart.
Claudius intended to finish what Julius Caesar had started and Caligula fail to
do,
conquer the mysterious island of Britannia and 43 eight d an invasion force was
sent to the island that year.
The Romans like the established a settlement that they called London Iom
compared to pass conquest.
The invasion of Britain would be a slow process taking around 40 years and
nearly ending into feet.
Claudius had made important conquests and political alliances in Britain.
He died in 53 Aidy,
possibly poisoned by his own wife and was followed by Emperor Nero.
Nero Nero would be remembered as yet another corrupt,
insane emperor he inherited and continued to the conquest of Britain.
There in the [inaudible] 68 [inaudible],
the king of a tribe known as the e Kenny or Roman ally,
prospect Targus died and left half his kingdom to Rome and the other half to his
daughters.
The Romans ignore this and annexed all of the territory from prospect tog is his
wife protested.
She was beaten and her daughters were raped.
His wife would not forget this treatment and she rose to challenge the Romans in
revolt,
her name was Boudica,
more properly pronounced Boudica.
Boudica would rally not only hurry Kenny tribe,
but also another tribe that Trina avant aes who rebellion around the year 68 d
they would attack and burn a number of Roman settlements,
including Londinium.
But in 61 80 her forces were defeated at the battle of watling street.
Shortly after [inaudible] died,
possibly from suicide or also sickness and 64 80 a great fire devastated much of
the city of Rome.
Many claimed Nero started the fire.
It is uncertain now.
This is true,
but either way he blamed the fire on an emerging religious minority.
Christians.
Many were tortured and executed.
As a result.
This was not in euros,
only act of cruelty and his behavior would lead to him being forced to commit
suicide to avoid assassination and 68 Aidy.
Thus came an end to the Julio,
Claudia and dentisty as Nero had no clear air.
The year 69 subsequently became the year of the four emperors,
has four emperors each,
tried to secure a stable rain until Tito's flowers.
We SpatialOS better known as a space alien.
Accomplish this.
[inaudible] was a respected,
known for his service in the initial invasions of Britain and victories over the
Jewish revolts in Syria.
Though a pragmatic and frugal man who never dreamed he would become emperor.
When he did,
he brought stability back to Rome,
which had been lost in the past year of competing emperors in past decades of
psychopathic emperors.
He introduced new taxes,
built a number of structures including the still standing Colosseum in Rome and
reignited the war in Britain,
the spacey and died in [inaudible] 79 and after his 10 year reign,
he was followed by his son.
Tito's though Tito's ruled for only two years,
it was an eventful two years.
It was under him that the greater eruption of Mount Vesuvius occurred.
He died from fever and 81 80 and rural pass through his younger brother,
[inaudible] Domitian emission would rule for 15 years completing the works of
his father and brother under him.
The Roman General Agricola pushed further into Britain even briefly ruling over
much of Caledonia Modern Day Scotland.
Importantly,
he ruled Rome during the first doc in war.
The doc Ian's were in ancient people living in modern day Romania in 87 eight d
led by a king named Deka Ball in the war of 86 to 88 80 but doc Ian's would
actually end up defeating Rome doc yet gained Roman recognition and became one
of the most powerful kingdoms on the Roman border,
partially because of the aid and funding Domitian provided them to keep them off
rooms.
Back in 96 a d Domitian was assassinated.
His successor Nerva died two years later and in 98 and a man named ty Ono's
Trajan became amber Trajan,
had been a successful commander and servant of the mission who had put down a
revolt and gear Manea and had even served as console as a reward upon becoming
emperor.
It was clear he would not have the same faults as Domitian and got to work to
secure the empire.
His integrity,
his first target doc yet and one o one eight d Trajan defeated the documents at
the second battle of the Pie,
the same location where a decade earlier,
the mission's generals had been defeated.
It's like a ball.
As soon as they're rendered.
The former treaty between docusign and Rome was ended and that Kabbalists became
a subordinate client king.
However,
Deka boss would use this piece to reorganize and prepare for another war with
Rome by preparing for war and inciting rebellion.
Trajan attacked again at one oh five 80 and at the battle of Somme Mesic Tusa
defeated them once and for all.
And Decca Bolis committed suicide.
Trajan had secured a great victory and it would be the first of many.
Much of his reign was spent expanding Rome's borders and in a sense,
neutralizing hostile threats.
And one 1580 trading would embark on the conquest of Parthenia his victories.
There would,
when Rome control of the territory surrounding the Tigris and Euphrates rivers,
a great accomplishment,
but they would not last.
Trajan died of old age while still expanding into the Middle East.
The Roman people would refer to him as optimum Preen Capes,
the greatest ruler.
He was a strong ruler who came to power in the middle of Pax Romana and brought
the empire [inaudible] and one 17 and the Roman empire.
It was powerful,
glorious,
wealthy and ruling over its greatest territorial extent from Scotland to Egypt
to Crimea,
to Morocco,
the generation of Romans living under trade and would continue to enjoy this
golden age even after his death,
living under the reigns of other great emperors like Hadrian who concerns
himself with building walls and other defenses around Rome and stabilizing Rome
internally and Marcus Aurelius,
the philosopher emperor.
However,
it was not destined to last forever and the one eighties UBC as series of
corrupt leadership will begin to drag the empire down,
putting it in critical condition and beginning a series of events that will
eventually lead to the fall of this mighty empire altogether.
In the next video,
we will pick up with the reign of Hadrian and explore the fate of Rome,
the emperors and events which sickened the empire and the emperors who would try
to save it.
I would like to thank you all for viewing the first fire of learning documentary
of 2019 it is the first of many documentaries and other videos to come as 2019
is the year that this channel enters the five d.
If you enjoyed this and found it informative,
I'd invite you to come check out some other cool content we have here on fire of
learning like these videos shown here,
and to subscribe to not miss out on future videos to help with the cost of
production.
Fire learning does take donations on Patrion,
the link to which you can find in the description.
You can support the channel with as little as a $1 contribution.
However,
simply subscribing to our youtube channel for free is also a large help.
Special thanks once again to our patrion supporters.
Let's to here we are also on Instagram and Facebook,
so come check us out there to cut out os [inaudible] for watching.